This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemisbeg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So the other day I did an episode on the five biggest regrets I have about my 20s so far. And one of those regrets that really stood out to a lot of you was this regret I have about focusing too much on dating in my early 20s. I remember being 19 in my college university dorm room downloading Tinder and being like, this better get me a boyfriend. Like I need a boyfriend.
I need to fit in. I need to have this like relationship that like others can see and that's like going to feel amazing. And this is going to make me feel really great about myself. And I got the boyfriend. It wasn't very satisfying. I ended up back in this cycle of again and again and again chasing validation from men, chasing validation from romantic partners that was actually pretty unfulfilling and took away
a lot of the time that I should have devoted to figuring myself out, to traveling, exploring, putting time and effort into friendships. You know, there was especially this relationship that I've spoken about before where, you know, the very fact that I was in that relationship cost me a lot of friendships. And it's something that I still think about fairly often. I still miss those friends so much. And I'm not even in that relationship anymore. And it's a huge regret of mine that romance often took precedence over not just all other kinds of love, but just everything in my life. Nowadays, we're seeing this incredible, and I would also say personally really admirable.
trend of decentering men, de-centering dating, taking your time to find the right person, honoring your single years, questioning what we sacrifice in a relationship as much as what we think we gain. And I thought, what a great time to investigate this trend of decentering romance, decentering men in our 20s and doing so from a psychological perspective. I want to talk about where this laser focus on love comes from in our 20s, why it might be holding us back in other areas of our lives, and how we can de-centre dating and needing to find our person during this decade so that we can be a little bit selfish, so that we can really focus on ourselves, so that we can have all that time and energy and effort and attention we put into others just for us when I think we really need it the
most. So without further ado, let's break. break down the psychology behind de-centering romance in our 20s. To start us off, I think we should first look at why we focus so much on love during this decade during these years. The first explanation and the easiest explanation is simply that love is really wonderful. Like, it is great. I'm not going to pretend that it's not. You and I both know. It is life-changing.
if it is with the right person. The thing is, though, nobody told us how hard it would actually be to find the right person. The storybook romances of our childhood, they are actually pretty few and far between. But because our society is based around ideals of marriage, unions, couples, families, we often feel like, or at least I remember feeling like the rest of my family, life would not start, could not start until I had firstly ticked off and get a boyfriend on my list. Get into a relationship was this thing that I had to do before, you know, I could progress into the next phase of my life before I could truly be an adult. There is this huge societal pressure
to find somebody so that you can, you know, move in together and then so that you can get married, get a mortgage, get a dog, have a kid. And that is a process that we feel very pressured to begin at actually what is quite a young age. Like your early 20s, you are still like very, very young. And yet in the back of your mind, there is this constant fear of like the clock is ticking, all the good ones are taken, my standards are just going to get lower, the dating pool is going get smaller, I feel like we all know this script. I always ask myself, how much of this is really just about social approval and social recognition and how much of this is actually purely about
the other person and really caring for them and having real true, deep, passionate feelings for another human. We are very naturally sensitive to what is publicly celebrated. Obviously, we instinctually as humans seek harmony and conformity, even if we think that we don't. And being in a relationship is a goal and is something that is very easy to recognize and applaud from the outside. It's not that we are shallow. It's not that like we are only doing this because other people expect it from us. It's just that we are very much aware and influenced by society's expectations and the fact that romantic milestones monopolize our sense of progress, even when our values are more complex than that.
You may have noticed this. You see a family member you haven't seen in a while. Sometimes even you have conversations with your friends, and it's never, you know, how excited are you for the future? Or what's like the big thing that you're working on right now? What are you excited about? What's your goal? It's always, so do you have a boyfriend yet? Do you have a girlfriend? Are you dating anyone? The conversation always comes back to that and it creates a lot of anxiety. Anxiety that influences our decision making. You know, this is another thing that I think about a lot and that I really wish my younger self had thought about a little bit more. Do you really want a boyfriend? Do you really want a girlfriend? Or do you just want the anxiety about being single?
to go away. Do you actually want a relationship? Or would it just stop you worrying about what you may be missing out on? Do you want a partner? Or do you want people to know that you have value because someone chose you? This is all stemming from deep fears about whether we're worthy, whether we are loved, whether we are accepted, whether we have value. This fear, this anxiety pushes us from a place of discernment, a place of rationality, intention and value into a place of urgency, a place of impulsivity, blindness, where we accelerate commitment, not because the fit is strong, not because we are even necessarily compatible, but because the timeline that we are experiencing in our 20s feels very fragile and feels very uncertain. What is the risk in this? What is the risk in centering romance
too much and too strongly in our 20s. The risk here is what we refer to as narrative foreclosure. We have the partner. We found the person on the dating app. And now that we're in the relationship and maybe we're a couple of years down the line, we genuinely believe it's too late to start over again. It's too late to get back out there. So you tolerate less and less and less and less and less
an amazing relationship for this good relationship, for this relationship that at least ticks the box of being partnered. And you know what, what should really, I really believe should scare us and scare you more than not finding somebody is actually finding the wrong person and confusing them with the right person. A lot of the time, rushing into relationships or marriages very young is actually more likely to see you. broken up or divorced later down the line because we are acting from a place again of urgency rather than discernment, which causes us to just choose wrong. A 2013 study published in the general couple and family psychology actually found that 61% of couples who recently got a
divorce cited that getting married too young was one of the main factors their relationship didn't work out. Simply being partnered when you're in your early 20s because you feel like have to, is not the same as being well matched and is not the same as having somebody you genuinely trust and are compatible with. And the risk is that you have this person and so you feel like a chapter in your life is closed maybe earlier than it should have. You've given this person some of the best years of your life. You've given them your youth and then now you're 30, 40 and you're like, why did I do that? Why was I in such a rush? I actually had so much time and I cannot get those years back. The biggest reason I think that we should be decentering romance in our 20s is because
ultimately this should be your selfish decade. If you want to spend a month in Greece, do it. If you want to move countries, do it. If you want to change who you are every four months, do it. Do you want to explore everything? Try it all, taste it all, see it all. Do it. Like having these goals and ambitions for yourself requires focus and it requires time and it requires you to be really honest and in touch with who you are. And when you focus, when your focus is on romantic love and romantic love only, don't confuse me. Your life is not about you anymore. It is about this faceless, elusive someone who will come into your life and save the day. If you are waiting to be chosen before your life really begins,
you are going to contort yourself, change yourself, lose yourself trying to impress somebody who might not even make your life better than what it could have been without them. So you lose your identity, you lose your priorities, you also lose your time. You know, centering romantic possibilities and centering dating is so time consuming. It is, it takes up valuable mental energy, getting to know somebody, replying to all these messages on dating apps, constantly trying to organize dates and remember whether they ghosted you or not. Like, it's basically a full-time job. I remember when I was dating fairly intensely for a couple of years there, if I had made a pie chart of what I spent time thinking about, and I was like pursuing my education, I had a really great
job, I had hobbies, still, 50% of the time I would be thinking about men and I would be distracted by what they were thinking about me. And it was all I could talk about with my friends. It was so time consuming and that was time that I don't get back that I could have used for rest or learning a new skill or making new friends or being creative. And I really do feel like it was in some ways wasted. I think maybe on a deeper level, sometimes we do this. We give up our time and we chase being chosen because we just want to feel like we belong and we want to feel like somebody sees us and loves us and that is a way to avoid truly being with ourselves. We get a fast hit of safety or self-esteem in the texts, in the plans, in the promises of being with somebody in
their potential. And I think we momentarily get a sense of relief that we might not be lonely forever, that maybe we're not that terrible. Maybe we do have value. And what we're really engaging in here is emotional bypassing. We're using the attention of other people to dodge the inner work because it feels safer to do so. Oftentimes we think, you know, when I'm in a relationship, everything change, I'll have the validation I'll need, I'll be happy because somebody else has confirmed for me that I have value. And the thing is, is that all that insecurity will still be there. And it will probably be made worse by the fact that perhaps you chose the first person who showed up at the front door, or you changed in order to be chosen. And now listen, it's fun today.
You know, I'm in a long-term relationship with an amazing guy. I'm not saying like, turn into a nun until you're 30, but there is a very. a difference between dating being a part of your life and dating consuming your life and consuming your time, energy, identity, and sense of self-worth. So after this short break, what I want to do is explore a nuanced, balanced, healthy approach to romance in our 20s that doesn't eliminate love, doesn't eliminate romantic love, but just de-centers it from being the main story we're trying to build for ourselves or tell ourselves. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator
available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific. con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here,
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Grega lesbian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In my humble opinion, I do truly believe that romance should not at any stage in your life be the main focus of your world, except for maybe like on your wedding day. How I describe it is my relationship and the love I feel for my partner is not my whole world.
it is a separate universe for which I step into, I get to enjoy, but I also step out of because you know, my world is my world. And me and my partner, our relationship does kind of exist separately from that. The moment that I'm spending too much time in this other universe or the moment that I feel like all my plans and all my behaviors need to be about him or our orientated towards him. This is like a really good sign to plant my feet firmly back into my own inner world and my own inner garden. So if you want to de-send to love in your 20s, if you want to have the world and then have the universe on the side, here's what you're going to do. Number one, firstly, you need to ask yourself, do I have love to share? We need to make sure our own cup
is filled up first, then you need to make sure you have enough in your cup to give to your loved ones, then you need to make sure you have enough in your cup to give to the things you care about. And if there is still something left over, then romantic love can be a priority. This reflects something that we call self-determination theory. And this theory basically maps the three needs that each of us should be fulfilling at any given time, the need for relatedness, competence, and autonomy. We need relatedness through friendship and community. We need competence through learning and creativity and we need autonomy by being able to make our own decisions. When we are fulfilling these three things, we can be discerning
about love and we can be discerning and make a conscious balanced choice about what we are choosing to spend our time on. If your cup is not overflowing, I don't think that romantic love is going to make it flow anymore. And if your cup is not overflowing and you want it to be, I want to tell you how you can make that so. How can you give yourself, I guess, more to give, more to give yourself, more to give others, more to give your life? This is the thing you're going to do. You are going to pick a Masogi challenge. Now, misogi is a Japanese term that is basically like a Shinto ritual where people would take like a sacred pilgrimage to a waterfall, it was a way to challenge themselves and then they would like purify themselves under the water. That's like the traditional version of a misoggi
in Japan. A modern misogy refers to a significant year defining challenge that we really want to commit to and do that requires a lot of focus and devotion on our. behalf to this thing. So basically it's like a pact that you make with a dream you really have to just spend the year giving it your all. A Masogi could be writing a book. It could be starting a podcast, running a marathon, launching a company, completing a multi-day hike, getting scuba certified, building something. And it's basically meant to require deep commitment and dedication from you the same way you might deeply commit and dedicate yourself to a relationship. So many of us live passively. Or so many of us focus on dating because it feels like a worthy project. But when you
have a masogi, you are laser focused. You have things to do. You have this task, this goal that is deeply personal to you that you really care about that nothing can get in the way of. This devotion to yourself, to a practice, to realizing a dream. It means that you really only have space left in your life for the kind of love that finds you organically and that adds to your life. All these other kinds of love that you may find on a dating app or that may be fickle or may come from people who aren't fully committing. You have your Misoji. Like you don't have time for those things.
So it allows you in a way to be very discerning and to let only good love in because you've got this big love here. You've got this thing you're really dedicated to. It's very similar advice to like getting a hobby, right? It's just on a whole new level. Here's the other thing. I think having a devotional practice like a Musogi or having hobbies, having interests that you may have lost in a previous relationship or may have lost to your devotion to dating, it actually makes you a much more magnetic person anyways. Like what I have found time and time again, the less you focus on dating, the more people like suddenly appear in your life who are worthy of your love.
You can call it the law of detachment. You can call it whatever you want to. But people who are committed to themselves and to doing cool stuff because they want to, that is so hot. People are deeply attracted to that. And I have found, like in the times where I've been devoted to something outside of myself and I've been really committed to making something and making something well and doing something cool, like suddenly you look around. It's like, wait, why are there suddenly all these prospects for me? Like, why they're all these people? It's because that, mentorship that you were experiencing through that changes how people see you and changes how you relate to yourself and just changes your energy field. Like I fully do believe it. My next tip
for decentering romance in your 20s is to have a dating detox. I know I've spoken about this a few times on the podcast. I really don't care. It's just so worthwhile to do. If you have noticed that dating is taking up a lot of space and energy, have a break. I genuinely do believe that the same way you can get burnt out at your job, you can get dating burnout. You can feel so deeply exhausted and disillusioned that dating is a chore to you rather than something that gives you energy. You are in this position of like, I just want to find somebody so I don't have to do this anymore.
I just want to finish this task at my job so I don't have to worry about it. This isn't a job. Dating isn't a job. it is not something that your livelihood depends on. You can just quit the rat race. You can quit the dating rat race and just say, I don't want to do this for a while. This is where I think the biggest challenge comes about.
Because what you have to fight against is really your milestone anxiety. And the part of you that might say, you're never going to find anyone. You know, you can't take a break now. The clock is ticking. Like, if you don't find somebody soon, like it's all going to be over for you. come on keep going you're going to strike gold soon and the thing is is like you're not running out of time three months of dating isn't going to kill you six months of not being on the apps isn't going to ruin your life in fact i think it's probably going to improve your life so delete or pause the apps
stop maintaining ambiguous connections with random people use that free time for sleep for exercise for self-nourishment for plans for work. And yes, you might expect a few restless days while your habits adjust, but I think it settles after a while. And you realize, like, I don't really need this anymore. This actually wasn't a worthwhile part of my life, at least not the way that I was approaching it. And when you do return, because of course, you know, you probably will, I think you'll be able to examine the relationship you have with these online connections or with these apps or with people in a much more constructive way. After I did my dating detox, like, I feel like this is a very famous story on the podcast. The first person I matched with after I did my dating detox is now my
boyfriend of three years, but obviously I was still like, you know, swiping at the same time as when I had matched with him. And I came back from my dating detox with solid rules. Like, I had rules for the people I matched with. I can't remember them exactly, but I think it was like, uh, 24 hours to message me after matching, six hours to reply, one to two weeks to organize a date. Otherwise, like, I would seriously just unmatch these people. Anybody who stopped replying after like a day, unmatched. Anybody who like wasn't going to plan a date, unmatched. Anybody who just like never actually messaged me. Unmatched. Like their profiles were digital cluttered to me. It was. It was taking up space in my mind to have them like to have them there, to have the unanswered message,
to have the weeks long conversation just staring at me. And when I like put my foot down and was like how you begin is how you, you know, how you commit to going on. So if these people aren't giving me enough at the beginning, I don't have high expectations for them in the future. once I decided that it was so relieving, it was so peaceful, it was just, it was just like a nice stoic mindset. It was like, yeah, it was just like, wow, I can just flow through this rather than getting constantly stuck on these people who I thought I had a future with. What you really have to remember is like your time is precious, your mindset is precious, your environment, whether it is offline or online, is precious.
进行了长达数周的对话，只是直勾勾地看着我。当我态度强硬，觉得“你开始的方式”就决定了你以后投入的方式。所以如果这些人一开始就没有给我足够的付出，我对他们以后的表现也不会抱太高的期望。一旦我做出这个决定，那种感觉真是太解脱了，太平静了，就像是一种非常美好的、斯多葛学派的心态。就好像，是的，感觉就像，哇，我可以顺其自然地度过这一切，而不是总是纠结于那些我以为会有未来的那些人。你真正要记住的是，你的时间是宝贵的，你的心态是宝贵的，你的环境，无论是线下的还是线上的，都是宝贵的。
and nobody who you have not met yet, who you don't have a deep connection with yet, is important enough for you to sacrifice that. Because you don't even know them. You know yourself. You know that you deserve love. You don't know if they deserve love yet. So give that love that you may eventually give to them to yourself
而且任何你还没遇到、还没有建立深厚联系的人，都不值得你为此做出牺牲。因为你根本不了解他们。你了解你自己。你知道你值得被爱。你还不知道他们是否值得被爱。所以，把你最终可能会给他们的那些爱，留给自己吧。
until you can prove that they are. Next, and maybe my favorite tip for decentering romance is to start dating your friends. And no, I don't mean, like, actually dating your friends. What I mean is, like, start pouring all that time, energy, love back into these platonic relationships. Apply the same effort you use for dating to your close bonds and close friendships. Put recurring plans on the calendar. Confirm them early in the week.
直到你能证明他们值得。接下来，也许是我淡化浪漫关系的秘诀中我最喜欢的一个：开始和你的朋友约会。不，我不是指那种真正和朋友约会的意思。我的意思是，开始把所有的那些时间、精力、爱，都倾注回这些柏拉图式的关系中。把你在约会时付出的努力，同样应用到你亲密的纽带和亲密的友谊中。把固定的聚会计划排进日程表。在周初就确认好。
Choose venues, get dressed up, and actually follow through. make date nights for your friends. I wish I did this more right now. It's been a little bit chaotic for me with moving to a new country and all, but I used to host these like elaborate date nights for me and my friends a couple months ago. Back in the day, I would do them all the time. And it was like themed dinner parties and like movie nights with like themed snacks and life drawing nights and art nights and really fun like dinner dates. And you know what? When I was single, those moments were like 99% of the time better than any date I ever went on. And honestly, sometimes I would find myself like on a date with a man and being like, damn, I really wish like my best friend was here.
选择地点，盛装打扮，并且真正付诸行动。为你的朋友举办约会之夜。我希望自己现在能多做一点。搬到一个新的国家等等对我的生活来说有点混乱，但几个月前我经常为我和朋友们举办这种精心策划的约会之夜。过去，我一直都在这样做。这就像主题晚宴、带主题零食的电影之夜、人体素描之夜、艺术之夜以及非常有趣的晚餐约会。你知道吗？当我单身的时候，那些时刻99%都比我经历过的任何约会都要好。说实话，有时候我会发现自己和某个男人在约会，心里却在想：天哪，我真希望我的闺蜜也在这里。
Like, I really wish my girlfriends were here. Like genuinely giving these ties the same love and attention that you usually hold for romantic connections just create such a beautiful opportunity for like deep love in a new form. At the end of the day, you know, you can find the love of your life tomorrow. Maybe you will, but like, they will never be enough to sustain you if you don't have these other platonic connections at your back. If you don't have these other people who are going to show you love and you show them love in a really important and healthy way. Okay, my fifth tip is to ask yourself the question. If I knew I would find the love of my life in six months, like we just spoke about, what would I do in the time?
就像，我真的希望我的女性朋友们也在这里。真心实意地给予这些关系同样的爱和关注，而这些通常是你留给浪漫关系的，这会为新形式的深爱创造一个如此美好的机会。说到底，你知道，你明天就可以找到你一生的挚爱。也许你会的，但是，如果你背后没有这些其他的柏拉图式关系来支撑你，他们永远也不足以支撑你。如果你没有其他这些人向你展示爱，而你也以非常重要和健康的方式向他们展示爱。好的，我的第五个建议是问自己这个问题：如果我知道我会在六个月内找到一生的挚爱，就像我们刚才谈到的那样，在这段时间里我会做什么？
time I have from then to now? What would I do before I met them? And I've spoken about this a few times, but I think this exercise works because it really asks you to do away with the concerns of being single and just pay attention to what you really want in your life. When you aren't distracted by this idea of choosing or being chosen, you know, what is on your single bucket list? What skills do you want to learn? What emotional wounds do you want to heal? What trips do you want to take? What health goals do you have?
从现在到那时我拥有的时间？在遇到他们之前我会做些什么？我之前已经谈过几次了，但我认为这个练习之所以有效，是因为它确实要求你抛开单身的担忧，只去关注你真正在生活中想要的东西。当你不再被选择或被挑选这个概念所干扰时，你的单身愿望清单上有什么？你想学习什么技能？你想治愈什么情感创伤？你想去进行什么旅行？你有什么健康目标？
Financial targets? Time spent with friends. Time spent with family. What unfinished goals would you like to achieve as a single person? I need you to make a single bucket list of experiences and milestones that you think might be better as a single person that you think would really contribute to your life. even when there's nobody else with you in it, even when you don't have a partner. I want you to at least have 15 things on that list. I know I feel like a drill sergeant, but I want results, 15 things on your single bucket list.
财务目标？与朋友相处的时间。与家人相处的时间。作为一个单身的人，你想要实现哪些未完成的目标？我需要你列一份单身愿望清单，上面写满那些你认为单身时会更好、并且真正能为你的生活添彩的经历和里程碑。即使你身边没有别人，即使你没有伴侣。我希望你的清单上至少有15件事情。我知道我听起来像个魔鬼教官，但我想要看到成果，你的单身愿望清单上要有15件事。
And now you've got those. I want you to choose two of them and plan to do something about it this week. And then after that, methodically, tick them off. and every time you complete to add two more on. The main point of this question, if I knew I would meet the love of my life in six months, what would I do? The main point is, again, it takes the worry off the table.
现在你有了这些。我希望你从中选择两样，并计划在本周付诸行动。在那之后，有条不紊地把它们勾掉。每次你完成时，就再添上两个。这个问题的核心意图——如果我知道我会在六个月内遇到一生的挚爱，我会做什么？核心意图是，再次强调，它消除了担忧。
It's no longer a consideration. And so all your focus is just on your ambitions and your desires. And you know what? If you do want a romantic relationship in the future, which of course most of us do, and that's not the problem here, But this exercise just encourages you to look at your life and genuinely think about the kind of person you would attract and you would want to be with based on how you are living your current life. Are you modeling the love that you would want to receive back?
它不再是一个考量因素。所以你所有的注意力都集中在你的野心和欲望上。你知道吗？如果你在未来确实想要一段浪漫的关系，当然我们大多数人都想，这并不是问题所在，但这个练习只是鼓励你审视自己的生活，并根据你目前的生活方式，由衷地思考你会吸引什么样的人、你想和什么样的人在一起。你在树立你希望得到的爱的榜样吗？
Are you modeling the kind of person that you would want to fall in love with? That's really like a really deep question. and like, would you fall in love with you? Because if the answer is no and you wouldn't fall in love with yourself first, then like there's probably a lot of work you need to do. Because it shows that there is probably like a deficit there in self-esteem, self-knowledge, in goals, in inspiration that like another person is never going to do anything about. They're never going to be able to fix it.
你在塑造你想要坠入爱河的那种人的形象吗？这真的是一个非常深刻的问题。就像，你会爱上你自己吗？因为如果答案是不，而且你没有首先爱上自己，那么你可能还有很多工作要做。因为这表明自尊、自我认知、目标、灵感等方面可能存在缺陷，而另一个人永远无法对此做任何改变。他们永远无法修复它。
My final piece of advice, and this might not be everyone's cup of tea, going on from what we were just talking about. I want you to do everything in your power during this period of your life to become utterly obsessed with yourself, to the point of arrogance, to the point of vanity. And I mean it, I want you to become obsessed with yourself. That is one of the only ways I see as being able to decenter romance or obsession from somebody else. And listen, I'm not worried about any of you going.
我的最后一条建议，这可能不是每个人的菜，接着我们刚才谈论的话题。我希望你在人生的这个阶段竭尽所能，变得对你自己彻底着迷，达到自负的程度，达到虚荣的程度。我是认真的，我希望你对自己着迷。这是我看到的能够将浪漫或对别人的迷恋淡化的唯一方法之一。听着，我不担心你们中的任何人会做得。
too far at all. I don't think you're going to end up being these like egotistical maniacs. I think if you're listening to a self-help podcast about decentering love, you've probably found yourself really lacking confidence in the past or being overwhelmed by dating or feeling really struck by how dating heart is and struck by how terrible you feel. So going heavy in the opposite direction with this self-obsession project, I think it's going to be a good counterbalance. to get you somewhere kind of back in the center, maybe even further to the right, of loving yourself and of genuinely thinking that you are amazing. Like, I need you to tell yourself, daily, I am a catch. Somebody would be lucky to have me. I am talented. I am so hot. I am so smart. I am fantastic.
太过分。我不认为你们最后会变成这些自大狂。我想如果你在听一个关于淡化浪漫的自助播客，你以前可能真的发现自己严重缺乏自信，或者被约会压得喘不过气来，或者对约会的艰难以及自己的糟糕感觉感到深受打击。所以在这个自我着迷的项目上朝相反的方向大举发力，我认为这将是一个很好的平衡点，能让你重新回到中心，甚至更偏右一点，去爱你自己，并且真心觉得自己太棒了。就像，我需要你每天告诉自己：我是个抢手货。谁能拥有我真是三生有幸。我很有才华。我太辣了。我太聪明了。我太棒了。
I need you to be like all in on celebrating yourself, all in on treating yourself like you, you are the best person on the planet because that's how a partner should make you feel about yourself. And so if somebody is turned off by you thinking great things about yourself, it's because they don't think highly enough of you. And they are intimidated by the fact that they can't get away with the bare minimum because you don't like yourself enough to not demand more. Being a little bit self-obsessed is the best barrier to entry for people who are never going to treat you right and it allows you not to decenter love altogether but to de-center mediocre love because you know you already have a fantastic thing going with you and yourself like
我需要你全力以赴地庆祝自己，全力以赴地把自己当成地球上最棒的人对待，因为这正是一个伴侣应该让你对自己的感觉。所以，如果有人因为你对自己有极高的评价而对你反感，那是因为他们对你的评价不够高。他们感到气馁，因为他们无法用最低标准敷衍了事，而你太爱自己，不会允许自己不去要求更多。有点自我着迷是对那些永远不会正确对待你的人最好的准入门槛，它能让你不至于完全淡化爱，而是淡化平庸的爱，因为你知道你和自己已经有一段美妙的感情了，就像
the relationship you have with yourself is amazing it's the best one you ever going to have so some average person cannot get between the love affair that you have with you like they're not worthy of it if they don't match if not exceed your self-obsession and your love level of love for yourself. I really do feel decentering love is such an important decision and thing that we should all aim to do, whether you're in a relationship or not, like, during your 20s. It really allows you to just ground yourself and like, what do I want from my life? How much free time would I have? How much energy and effort would I have if this wasn't a priority? And what could I do at that time? You know, when your time and attention are,
你和自己的关系是美妙的，这是你将拥有的最好的一段感情，所以任何普通人都无法介入你和自己的这场恋爱之中，如果他们无法匹敌甚至超越你的自我着迷以及你对自己的爱，他们就不配拥有。我真的觉得淡化对浪漫的追求是一个非常重要的决定和我们都应该努力去做的事情，无论你是否处于恋爱中，在你的20多岁时。它真的能让你脚踏实地，去思考：我究竟想从生活中得到什么？如果这不是首要任务，我会有多少空闲时间？我会有多少精力和努力？我那时能做些什么？你知道的，当你的时间和注意力，
distributed to things that you really care about, your whole aura, your whole way of being is just elevated. And you just achieve, do, see, believe, love more. And I think that's a really great place to be in before you start looking for somebody else to add to that. You know, looking for somebody else to maybe fill parts of you that you weren't able to fill yourself. If nothing else, just prove to yourself that you can. Just prove to yourself that you can. Just prove to yourself that yes, having somebody might be and is nice, worse comes to worse, you might not need it. Because you really do have like everything you have ever needed to make yourself happy. And if you don't have everything you've ever needed to make yourself happy,
分散到你真正关心的事情上时，你的整个气场、你的整个生存方式都会得到提升。你会收获、做到、看到、相信、爱得更多。我认为在开始寻找另一个人来为之锦上添花之前，这是一个非常棒的状态。你知道，寻找另一个人来填补你那些自己无法填补的部分。退一万步讲，只需向自己证明你能做到。只需向自己证明你能做到。只需向自己证明，是的，拥有某个人可能是而且确实很好，但最坏的情况下，你可能并不需要它。因为你真的拥有让你快乐所需的一切。如果你没有让你快乐所需的一切，
your friends definitely do. And your hobbies definitely do. And your community definitely does. Then you can go looking for it in romantic love. So I hope that you have enjoyed this episode. I hope you enjoyed the discussion. hopefully my passion came through on this. I know it's ironic that I've been with somebody who's amazing for like three years.
你的朋友们绝对有。你的爱好绝对有。你的社区绝对有。然后你再去浪漫的爱情中寻找它。所以希望你喜欢这一集。希望你喜欢这个讨论。希望我的热情能够通过这一集传递出来。我知道这很讽刺，我和一个非常棒的人在一起已经三年了。
And yet I'm still able to rant about this, mainly because I know that I would not be with him and I would not have found him if I hadn't gone through this whole process myself. And it's not to say, do it so that you can find love. I genuinely really was like so detached from the outcome when I decented love in my 20s, earlier in my 20s, that I really was happy with never finding anyone and it's, yeah, just kind of surprised me. And my standards were high and they continued to be high. And it just meant that the love fit in perfectly with the life I'd already built and continue to
然而我仍然能够对此高谈阔论，主要是因为我知道，如果我自己没有经历过这整个过程，我是不会和他在一起的，也不会找到他。这并不是说，去做这件事是为了让你能找到爱。我在20多岁时（20多岁出头）淡化浪漫追求时，我真的对结果极其超然，以至于我真的满足于永远找不到任何人，而且，是的，这有点让我自己感到惊讶。我的标准很高，而且还会继续保持高标准。这意味着爱情完美地融入了我已经建立并继续为自己
build for myself. So I want that for you guys as well. And I do really feel like this is a pathway to maybe not find that, but to find just find peace, find peace and like the chaos of dating. If you enjoyed this episode again, remember that this episode was also on YouTube. So if you want to go and subscribe to our channel for future video episodes, please feel free to do so. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. It's December in like a week, I feel like in less than a week. So we have our famous 12 days of guest episodes coming. Every December, I just interviewed the coolest people that I've had the opportunity.
构建的生活中。所以我希望你们大家也能如此。我真的觉得这是一条途径，也许不一定是为了找到那种爱，而是为了找到平静，在约会的混乱中找到平静。如果你再次喜欢这一集，请记住这一集也在YouTube上有播出。所以如果你想订阅我们的频道以观看未来的视频节目，请随时这样做。确保你在Instagram上关注我：@that psychology podcast。大概再过一周就是十二月了，我觉得不到一周了。所以我们即将迎来著名的“节日12天”嘉宾访谈。每年十二月，我都会采访我有机会结识的
to meet this year and I get to, you know, bring those conversations to you guys. So if you want to be up to date with who we've got coming on the podcast, we have a plastic surgeon, we have somebody who runs a Renaissance fair, we have financial consultants, we have authors, like all these cool people, make sure you're following us on Instagram and subscribe slash following, whatever you are listening right now. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. you're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keir Games.
最酷的人，并把这些对话带给你们。所以，如果你想了解我们播客即将邀请到谁——我们请到了整形外科医生、文艺复兴集市的运营者、财务顾问、作家，所有这些酷炫的人——请确保你在Instagram上关注我们，并订阅/关注你现在正在收听的任何平台。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Keir Games）为你带来的《Learn the Hardway》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to Learn the Hardway on the AHA radio app,
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用上收听《Learn the Hardway》，
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
苹果播客，或任何你获取播客的地方。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO.%，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
她们都曾和同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the little. Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens, finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。